the search for seven missing girls in
Michigan continues this morning after
police say a convicted killer bragged
about their murders the girls have been
missing for decades one of them is
12-year old Kimberly king who was last
seen in 1979 Nikki petit is in Macomb
Township near Detroit where
investigators say they're making
progress in the cold cases Niki good
morning good morning officials here are
about to start their fourth day
excavating this land FBI agents and
police are just beginning to arrive this
morning rain here overnight mate search
conditions difficult but they say they
will continue until the remains are
found we do have as you know probable
cause to believe that this is a
gravesite at a press conference
yesterday Commissioner Bill Dwyer
suggested investigators were making
progress in this densely wooded area
they believe holds Kimberley King's
remains what have you found have you
found anything on this land yes but I'm
not gonna comment on what we found but
we do something that makes you believe
that remains are here this makes us very
cautiously optimistic that we're on the
right track Kimberly King disappeared in
1979 when she was 12 years old her best
friend
Annie danke was the last person to see
her alive something horrible happened to
her that day I know that she did not run
away this search area has been on police
radar since 2008 when convicted killer
Arthur Reem pointed them to the remains
of 13 year old Cindy Czar's ickey Reem
was already in prison for sexual assault
when he was convicted of SARS Ickes 1986
murder but this time he is not talking
to police authorities also believe
Arthur Eames recent confessions to
inmates and a failed polygraph test
related to the crimes helped bring the
case back in the spotlight I know how
they feel on Wednesday Edwards our Ziggy
came back to the site where his daughter
was found 10 years ago to show support
for the families of the remaining
missing girls I had to say that people
just pray that the person who in charge
or who did this will have the heart to
let him know what happened before
Kimberly King's grandmother died she
bought side by side burial plots the
family says she always believed her
granddaughter would be found and wanted
her laid to rest beside her John Nikki
Thanks
just gives me the chills yes yes gives
me the chills you know we talked about
this abstract notion of closure in these
horrible cases and you see the Kimberly
King's grandmother you know the buying
the burial plot I mean that's the way in
which this still carries on in a family
with these unanswered questions it's
very tough story thanks Nikki